[Musique]
la cathédrale notre dame sur l'île de la
cité et le coeur de paris son parvis
marque le kilomètre zéro d'où partent
toutes les routes de france commencé à
la fin du 12e siècle c'est un des plus
beau joyau du gothique français les
travaux ont duré 191 saint louis a
apporté la couronne des pink aurait
porté le christ jeanne d'arc qui a été
réhabilitée dans un nouveau procès
treize ans après sa mort napoléon s'est
fait sacrer et victor hugo on a fait le
théâtre d'un de ses plus grands romans
elle est sortie indemne de deux guerres
mondiales et de l'occupation allemande
elle attire près de 13 millions de
visiteurs chaque année
elle était en pleine restauration il y a
quatre jours à peine des seize statue de
cuivre ont été décrochés de la flèche de
la cathédrale pour être restaurées
opération spectaculaire que cet
enlèvement des douze apôtres et des
quatre évangélistes de trois mètres de
haut et 250 kg elle devait retrouver
leur place à la fin de la restauration
en 2022
cette flèche a disparu ce monument
abriter des oeuvres irremplaçable
d'abord ces trois grande rosace du xiiie
siècle au cas où si les vitraux qui sont
d'une valeur inestimable on peut penser
à la grande rose transept sud qui
représente la cua khalip puis qui est
franchement un chef-d'oeuvre de
l'architecturé gothique rayonnante tout
ce qui vit trop évidemment éclaté sous
le feu de l'action de la chaleur de la
pression du causés par le feu
sous une des rosaces les grandes orgues
les plus célèbres du monde il manque
d'instruments qui contient plus de 8000
tuyaux et cinq claviers commencé au
xvème siècle et à grand qui
continuellement
c'est un des instruments les plus
importantes france parce que les grandes
orgues l'institution les grandes orgues
de la cathédrale notre-dame de paris
c'est lé plus dans les plus importantes
de france d'ailleurs
donc c'est très prestigieux les
organismes qui joue ce n'est personne
très réputé il ya plusieurs toiles qui
datent surtout donc du xviie siècle
xviiie siècle en est certaine une wii et
des sculptures aussi on vend des nombres
et plusieurs en marbre qui ont peut-être
été fracassée au moment où on se parle
mais tout ce qui est boiteux ce qui est
issu tout ce qui est à peace rivaux être
entièrement conçu comme moteur
entièrement détruit par les sens
selon jean sébastien sauvé notre dame
doit être considérée comme une double
cathédrale et l'une d'entre elles est
une perte presque totale la charpente
on l'appelait la forêt et la cathédrale
de pierre ménes entendu mais ici il faut
considérer les chars penser qu'ils ont
créé la cathédrale de bois qui sur la
cathédrale de pierre comme étant un
chef-d'oeuvre ousty d'importance quand
même faut penser qu ouvrir un espace
aussi vaste que notre dame de paris avec
une toiture fallait le faire donc
c'était des génies tous ces charpentiers
là étaient des génies au même titre que
les tailleurs de pierre les pertes sont
considérables en termes de structure on
le devine mais maintenant on a hâte de
savoir ce qui a pu être sauvée des
trésors inestimables de notre dame de
paris
patrimoine de l'humanité jean michel
leprince sera du canada à montréal